So now, we have two hypotheses and we'd like to test them.
The null hypothesis is the basic hypothesis that something is correct
and unless proven wrong, we always believe null hypothesis is actually correct,
we trust the manufacturer or do we have sufficient evidence to be very high likelihood
the null hypothesis is wrong, the alternate hypothesis is correct then,
we reject the null hypothesis and we tell the manufacturer,
please print the label on the box because the number there isn't quite correct.
So let's do it. To recap, we have sample 11 yeses and 4 nos.
And our null hypothesis is equals p=0.9 and our alternate hypothesis, if it doesn't work,
as well as the null hypothesis, so p is smaller than 0.9.
This is a very exact to the setup you're going to study when we make hypothesis test.
If you look at the sample and it's obvious this is binomial
which is the fancy word for coin flips, binary experiments.
With 15 different experiments and under the null hypothesis  probably goes 0.9.
So obviously, in this binomial distribution, there are about 16 different outcomes from 0 to 15.
The most likely is 13, 14 is also pretty likely if the null hypothesis is correct,
and then the probability goes back to be down.
The key is assume that H₀ is actually correct, so the probability is 0.9,
then FIND was called the critical region under which 5% or less
of the total probability of this binomial designs for different lane.
You will place a mark over here that separates outcomes that invalidate the hypothesis
and outcomes that validate the hypothesis, so that all the outcomes, together, left off this marker
collect in totality at most the confidence level, in this case 5%.
So that if you find an outcome that sits to the left of this point,
you can say wow this outcome was so insanely unlikely under the null hypothesis, I just don't buy it.
If conversely the outcome is somewhere in this green box and it isn't that unlikely after all.
Realize that each outcome itself might have a small likelihood,
but you don't care about the probability of the outcome itself.
Even the maximum of the outcome has a small probability in this model.
All you care about is putting a separator within and except this region
and what's called the critical region and again the logic is
the critical region collects many possible outcomes, but in totality,
these probabilities don't exceed the 5%.
So if the final outcome is in the critical region, you can confidently say,
wow, I'm really surprised I don't buy that H₀ is correct.